The following elements
should have focus.
Header links,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Search fields, form input fields,
and the Submit button,
our large Call to Action button,
and footer links.
I'm not going to add tabindex
to any of these headings.
to any of these headings or
the paragraphs of text.
Even if that content seems super
important, it's not something the user
can interact with, so
there's no reason to make it focusable.
Similarly, even if this big
image is really awesome,
there is no reason to make it focusable.
Screen reader users will still be able
to understand the content of the image,
so long as we provide
proper Alt tag support,
which Alice will touch on
in just a few lessons.